pastor Kabbalah has attracted a number
of influential guests into his kingdom
from the Filipino President Gloria
macapagal-arroyo to Senators and
military commanders but his ministry has
not been without controversy in 2008 a
widow claimed in the Filipino press that
her husband was killed by unidentified
gunmen days after he refused to sell his
land to people she said were connected
to the kingdom kibbeh Lloyd dismissed
the claims was totally false and
baseless many of those detractors of
ours you know sometimes pick up some of
those people that are against us and say
Oh pastor Keebler is a land grabber
Apollo is a land grabber and then the
media pick it up you know because it's
sensationalized especially when it comes
to my name they sensational eyes it and
as I said I can care less about that
because if I had any violations of the
law you can find me in court I have my
legal team I have my lawyers to take
care of that attention was also focused
on the kingdom in 2004 arlene real Owens
parents accused kibbe law and his
followers of kidnapping their daughter
and leading a cult that exploits - I
can't say that pastor brainwash me or
anything it was my decision to follow my
calling because I know that what pastor
did even how many years ago when he was
called by the Father and he was trained
I know that he is my model and what I
chose to what I have chosen to follow my
calling here in the kingdom is just the
right thing to do for me
Arlene's dispute with her parents is
common amongst families who are involved
in new religions people in these groups
feel that they're getting more love from
the group as opposed to the genuine love
that comes from their families and then
many families feel that their children
their adult children are throwing away
their lives and not using their talents
in the way that they were pursuing
before they became involved kibble oi
and the kingdom appeared to be very open
about these accusations and said they
have nothing to hide these apparent
inconsistencies with his Messiah claims
also seemed to have no effect on the
congregation if you have any doubts and
you want to know the true way our
beloved pastor said that all you have to
do is go directly don't ask any man go
to the Almighty father say father who is
this man who is pastor policy keloid
where should I go to be truly saved and
become a son and daughter and the father
will answer you and I believe that he'll
show you the way to is kingdom which is
already here on this earth
we return to the cat 80-pound compound
in the city the kibble oiz Monday night
TV show give us this day
[Music]
through his television ministry kibble
oi says he's delivering his message of
repentance to millions of people each
week as the day of the Lord judgment of
evil is also the day of his reign on the
earth where as I said man's will is no
longer to be reckoned with it is the
Father's will that is to be reckoned
with at the moment the kingdoms growth
throughout the Philippines and the rest
of the world appears to be gaining
momentum but does his divine mission as
the second coming also contain more
earthly desires if our own Filipino
nation would wake up one day and would
come to the appointed son and say be our
president
you know politically and make the
Philippines just like this I would be
wholeheartedly there to do it for them
and in no time at all the father's
blessings will be upon this nation and
this nation is going to be a showcase
also for other nations